let's get started by taking a look at
this first story this this one from nbc
news
one of the most shocking stories and i
think
let me read the headline
biden has been presented with options
for massive cyber attacks against russia
the options presented include disrupting
the internet across russia shutting off
power and stopping trains in their
tracks they say
biden has been presented with with the
the menu of options for the u.s to carry
out cyber attacks to disrupt russia's
ability to sustain its military
operations in ukraine four people
familiar with the deliberations tell nbc
news this is important because they're
not talking about retaliation this is
not some story where they said we've
presented potential cyber attacks
against russia in the event they attack
us no this is we want to have the u.s
attack russia to stop their operations
in ukraine now many people have believed
that we should be backing up ukraine
many believe that we shouldn't
regardless
this story i believe is a threat to
vladimir putin the purpose of publishing
this is so that putin knows the u.s is
prepared to do it if the u.s wages cyber
war against russia going after their
internet their trains they are
attempting to [ __ ] their economy
economic damage is warfare
scary stuff man
yeah
it's it i mean it's no different than if
we were to go and bomb these same train
routes you know there's less death and
violence but the same objective from a
warfare standpoint is achieved and
that's the shutting down of the economy
and that has
major repercussions that
no country is going to ignore so
when when you're putting these options
on the on the table you know you said it
perfectly are we thinking about
retaliation because
we're not immune to that we we've
already seen over the past year i mean
we've seen several cyber attacks over
the past year we know that our
networks are just as vulnerable if not
more vulnerable to those same cyber
attacks so do we really want to start
that tit for tat
no we definitely and that's i don't i
don't think there's a winner in that
game it may already be happening there
was a ref was it the refinery explosion
yeah
yeah yeah when was that last night or
when was it so that was the day before
it was yesterday i think and it just
blew up and they had no idea why so i
still didn't figure it out i was just
like is this possible
yeah just it was a food processing plant
exploded
hey look i don't want to i don't want to
connect dots where we have no reason to
connect
putin i was listening to an interview a
couple years ago he was talking to like
a crowd and saying that america's
military defense capabilities basically
the last 20 to 30 years they've been
building up their defensive capabilities
against intercontinental ballistic
missiles and missile defense and now
that weaponry is so advanced and evolved
that all that defense's stuff is
obsolete and so all this american we
think we've got these great
complete obsolete lessons i mean anyone
that wants to kill right now any
government that wants to blow up a
country can do it i don't think they can
any any super power us china or russia
if they want to level something they can
level it there's going to be
consequences obviously but
we're not safe
like we're not living in like a bubble
here guys i don't well just just imagine
if some way somebody were to shut off
the the subway system in new york city
imagine the type of chaos that would
ensue from something
just as as simple as as one target like
that
that's that's an incred you don't need
bombs
you could you could turn a country
inside out on itself with some of these
cyber attacks you know you could cause
shortages in the supply chain you could
cause disruptions in major cities
imagine new york city in a traffic jam
of
nine million people who can't get around
all of a sudden what happens then
and a lot of people don't realize
because people have like a movie-esque
view of warfare
the targeting of civilians
wins you wars look at world war ii we
blew up two cities killed untold numbers
of i mean massive numbers of civil at
least two cities and they beg please
please please stop
it's a scary thought but you've got a
lot of people who have this view of
warfare as like i love the idea of war
crimes
when you're dealing with the idea of war
crimes you're not really dealing with
real war necessarily what i mean what i
mean by that is
when you can wag your finger and say the
international court will hear what
you've done that's not war that that
that i mean it's it's it's like it's
it's a lower tier of what war could be
when you're talking about actual
existential war then you're talking
about people saying i am going to evis
scorched earth your cities because you
got to understand about targeting of
civilians who do you think is making the
machines who do you think is running the
economy who do you think is producing
the food it's not like military is is
hammering away and smelting it's not
like it's all military farming it's
regular people so when you look at say
the civil war sherman's march to the sea
that's what the north said we wipe out
the farms we wipe out the people we win
the war and boy is that dark stuff but
that's real war that's brutal war i'm
pretty sure dresden the reason that the
allies firebombed dresden in world war
ii which was really one of the greatest
atrocities of the war
arguably had to happen because that's
where they were but it was a weapons
manufacturing hub basically so they were
like you know what we're taking them all
out full of civilians this is it like if
a terrorist has a building
and they're firing at you and then they
have a family in there with them
do you unload on the building with your
with your m1 abram and just level it to
the ground the answer in warfare is yes
because you're being fired at from that
building they're usually
people will use human shields man i was
watching these videos out of ukraine and
uh the subway systems in kiev where
everyone was piling in trains what
people need to know is
the subway systems in in kiev i i i
believe probably most of ukraine go deep
underground like legit when i was there
and i'm taking the train the escalator
escalators going down seemingly endless
and it's because during the cold war
when they're building these things they
were worried about nuclear strikes and
trains are extremely
if not the most important piece of
infrastructure oh yeah transporting
people and goods so they said if there's
one if we're going to protect anything
with deep underground bunkers we got to
get our train systems to move goods
you take a look there's a story out of
new york it's fascinating there's like a
secret room in grand central station
that contains this old machine that used
to run all of the tracks and it was
hidden behind like a secret wall or
something i don't know if you could
fashion me on the story but something
like this the reason was
if any of our adversaries say cold war
adversaries found it shutting down that
one machine would [ __ ] the us economy
you gotta understand man when the u.s
says we're going after your trains
that is level one of of starting the war
we are going to shut down your ability
to transport materials and and and
maintain your economy
and the report is so specifically we can
shut down your efforts in ukraine it's a
form of siege warfare really if you're
crippling their ability to transport
food to their citizens you're you're
putting them under siege and i think
it's i think it's
it's extremely reckless to put that
threat out in the open right it just it
seems it seems like a flagrant um
wag of the finger or a middle finger
into the face
of somebody who is
clearly already
um
easily provoked yeah doesn't it seem
strange that we are having this
conversation about this doesn't this
seem like something we should keep on
the down low am i crazy well exactly why
would they want to know why
intentional there's a reason
they're they're basically saying
vladimir putin we intend to attack you
and they knew having biden say this he'd
come oh
it's like no we can't even let our
president say it we gotta put it in the
news yeah that bad what did someone say
joe biden said chew grain instead of
ukraine or something like that yeah
someone chatted this i don't know i
didn't see the clip but uh
wow a president that can't command
there's there's a whole bunch of memes
about you know what's going on and it's
like there's one that's braveheart
and it's like barack obama and then it's
you know mel gibson no and then trump
comes that says trump four four trumps
you know for each year and he's like
hold and then it's biden no charge
yeah it's it's look there's something to
be said for that there's something to be
said for the fact that
throughout love love them or hate them
throughout the trump years we didn't
have these type of situations
uh bubbling up to the surface right in
front of us where people seem to be able
to do whatever they want without fear of
recourse
i mean
that's there's something to be said for
that type of posturing and
i think if you want to keep the world a
safe place
you have to be able to to do that to a
certain extent you see what rachel
maddow said oh my gosh but the reason
that putin didn't attack ukraine under
trump was because trump's position was
aligned with
putin's or something like that moscow
yeah yeah with moscow of course they're
still selling that russian collusion
narrative right
to a certain degree though i don't think
she's she i think she's tactless but
there there's
one issue is the issue of nato i mean we
brought it up on the show that trump was
like why are we still in nato like
what's the purpose here and so putin was
like
okay like let's see what happens however
i do think in my opinion
i think trump was
too erratic
i don't think that vladimir putin was
like finally a president who's gonna
work it for my favor no that makes no
sense because he was moving on ukraine
under obama he wanted crimea the eastern
the eastern regions had already declared
independence he waited until there was
someone weaker in office and i think the
re i think the issue is certainly maybe
you know it may be that when when trump
was questioning nato and saying they
should pay more putin was like we'll see
what happens
but that just seems like a stretch the
simpler answer is donald trump was
called a madman by his own followers by
his own fans they called him the madman
they called him the god emperor vladimir
putin's like
got to be careful with a man like that
he's erratic he could he could you can't
predict necessarily what he's going to
do now it doesn't mean that putin is in
a sense he's looking at a reflection of
himself
absolutely there's there there's a lot
of aspects about vladimir putin that are
very similar and you can't predict what
they're going to do they're extremely
hard-headed individuals
um you know and and again it's not it's
not do you like it do you not like it
it's what what keeps the wolves at bay
how much you want to bet you see that's
that that statement from joe biden about
a minor incursion remember that yeah
they were like what do you do if russia
invades it depends on whether it's a
minor incursion or not you know i'll see
what we'll do and then everyone's like
he's basically saying the u.s is a
tolerance level for a russian invasion
of ukraine and then biden was like
that's their line i can push it a little
bit
i can't believe let me let's pull this
map real quick
yeah what did i say
oh yeah push and push down
no but biden the only thing he pushes is
his wheelchair is he's going to the sun
go to sleep
check out this map
they hid everywhere i mean this is crazy
yeah uh through belarus it's it's
absolutely insane comprehensive oh and
this map isn't even is it even
comprehensive it's levi is not even on
this map
so
you know i was talking to my friend from
uh from kiev and she was just telling me
like all of these cities that were hit
so what it may be is that russians
russia's got special forces or some you
know some kind of uh
you know ground troops who had already
infiltrated kiev and then staged these
low-tier attacks to cause widespread
chaos confusion and panic
seems to sounds right there's a lot of
russian sentiment in ukraine from what
i've heard what i've been learning about
i mean it used to be part of the soviet
union and a lot of people in the soviet
union felt a lot of kinship towards
russia and
you know it all kind of spawned from
russia in the beginning
um the russian revolution and so on
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there